you got the climate leaders going to
Dubai going going in their private jets
to one of the hottest places on Earth to
fight the sun monster but then you've
got the the followers and the followers
don't have private jets and the
followers don't go to Dubai the
followers are very very concerned that
if we don't open up the caps on our
plastic water bottles everyone is going
to die of thirst I just picked this up
it's a full bottle of water and I'm on
this quest to dump out any water that
gets trapped in the plastic because once
it's trapped in these plastic bottles we
now have lost it basically forever so
it's really important when you see hi
doggo when you see water that's
discarded to open it up and dump it
out um alternately to make sure that
when you're done with water and that
goes for like you know juices or sports
drinks or whatever dump that out if
you're not going to use it because if
you don't it's it's trapped forever and
we've lost that water um to our
ecosystem so
thanks I'm no ecological expert I don't
think the water is lost
forever I think the vast majority of it
just gets kind of crushed up and
expelled at landfills and recycling
plants and other garbage facilities and
I I think I think we're going to be okay
on the water I don't think that your
tightening a a plastic Poland Spring cap
is going to uh cause all of us to die of
thirst what is this how is this woman so
worried about your plastic water bottles
this
is the climate religion's version of
scrupulosity scrupulosity is is an
obsession over sin a a a neurotic
obsession over sin so in True Religion
you you would be obsessed with whether
you had uh wished death on somebody
whether you had stolen something whether
you had had impure thoughts whether you
had violated actual moral laws and in
the climate religion which is a parody
of religion it it's a a parody of True
Religion and it's a a re return I
suppose of the old nature worshipping
Pagan religions there what you obsess
over is whether a drop of water got
stuck in your your bottle before you
sent it off to the landfill this is Peak
neurosis and they don't stop to think
that hold on a second I'm worried about
a drop of water in my water bottle
meanwhile John kery is flying off to
Arabia in a private jet spewing 20 times
the pollution into the air that he he
would otherwise spew if he were flying
commercially huh he he doesn't care
about this that much why should I care
about this this very minor thing they
don't really think about that because
they they buy the the argument and the
argument has a kernel of truth to it
John KY is right when he says my private
jet isn't going to cause the end of the
world that's true his private jet is a
drop in the bucket when we talk about
pollution also all the private jets
aren't going to cause the end of the
world also all the plastic water bottles
are not going to cause the end of the
world also the nature worshiping Pagan
religions are false and they were
supplanted for a Time by by the True
Religion and now we're living in
something much closer to the earliest
days of Christianity than we are to say
a thousand years ago or 500 years ago at
the very height of Christian
civilization we are living in A A A
Brave New World animated by a different
set of beliefs right now go to
expressvpn.com micheles show it's
extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN and choosing a
VPN you trust is equally as important I
can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why number one expressvpn does
not log your online activity they've
developed a trusted server technology
that makes it impossible for their
servers to store any data at all number
two speed expressvpn does not slow down
your user experience you can even stream
HD videos with zero buffering number
three expressvpn is incredibly easy to
use just fire up that app and tap one
button to connect not just me saying
this Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
my link expressvpn.com Michel NS show
today get three months free on a
one-year package
expressvpn.com
michelow expressvpn.com
show today George Soros and his son Alex
Soros who's taking over the George Soros
left-wing financing
Empire they have just maxed out
donations to Joe Biden's 2024
reelect now maxing out donations is a
little bit misleading here because we
have all these weird campaign Finance
rules maxing out donations means they
each gave
$6,600 which is nothing that's the
amount of money they make every time
they blink okay $6,600 is not going to
matter at all to the campaigns now
they'd also given a quarter million
dollars to the Biden Victory fund
which is much less regulated than the
the actual candidate Campaign Committee
but the reason that they're doing this
is not about the six grand or whatever
12 13 Grand and it's not about even the
quarter million dollars it's about
signaling to the rest of the left that
the big dog funders are still with Biden
the hardest hit person here is Gavin
Nome followed by kamla har Pete Budaj
all these other Jokers who want to take
Biden's spot there's still a ton of
support major institutional support for
Biden what's really funny too is you see
on the left basically all despite
Biden's extremely low approval
ratings all of the left the elite and
even uh a lot of the Grassroots they're
still backing Biden on the right the ire
Elite basically hates Donald Trump even
though he's the guy who's running kind
of as an incumbent he's leading the pack
by 4050 points you're still seeing these
major establishment Elite networks
donating a ton of money to other
candidates even candidates who are
polling at something like 9% you look at
the coke Network and Nikki Haley shows
you just a major difference between the
left and the right the left pretty much
put together marching and lock step the
right at each other's throats carved up
into at least two maybe three three
factions they can't figure it out but
the the people it would appear will
tolerate Joe Biden Joe Biden even
without the superdelegates even without
trying to push Bobby Kennedy out Joe
Biden would still win the nomination
there's no question about that for the
Democrats they would be the people on
the Democrat side would still basically
be in line with the elite and the
leaders on the right the elite and the
leaders are totally
opposed to the the people in terms of
which candidate they
back 50% or more of of Republican voters
back Donald Trump if you if you pulled
Republican Elites I bet something like
60 to 80% of the Republican Elites
especially the guys with the money
oppose Trump man what a great clip that
was now hey hey hey hey hold up got to
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NES YouTube channel we'll see you next
time